كيف امه المدن الروسيه كلام نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي نعم لا مؤشرات معلنه
رسميه بشان الهجوم الشامل على العاصمه لكن
الواقع على الارض مؤشراته تقول عكس ذلك
روسيا الان مضره لاستخدام الطريق الاقصر
انطلاقا من بيلاروسيا والسبب هو فشلها في
السيطره على خاركيب وسومي وهنا عدت
اوكرانيا مفاجاه للروس تحصينات دفاعيه على
طول الحدود جدران اسمنتيه
وحقول الغامه العبور لخط الدفاع الاول لا
يعدو تحدي كبير لكن هذه المره روسيات تعول
على دباباتها المحدثه في 90 ام وتي 14
بميزاتها المهمه درعا تفاعلي ينفجر بمجرد
اقتراب الصواريخ المضاده للدبابات ويعني
ذلك ان المدرعات الروسيه قال لن تكون
فريسه السنجر او
واحد يقود الى كييف وهنا التجربه في صالح
الاوكرانيين والبدايه من تشرنوبل ثم بوتشا
واربين واوكرانيا حولت هذه المدن الى
تحصنه ادفاعيه سيناريو باخموت يبدو انه
سيتكرر الهجوم الشامل ممكن باهداف اقل
رمزيات خيار اخر بيدي بوتن مدينته بوابه
اوكرانيا نحو الغربه وهي الاخرى غير بعيده
300 كلم تفصل
بيلاروسيا عن الفيف والسيطره عليها يعني
الكثير قطعوا الامدادات الغربيه وبدونها
لن يصمد طويلا لكن هذا الخيار يحمل عده
مخاطر والاول ان البيئه قريبه جدا من
الحدود الفولنديه سقوط صاروخ او قذيفه
واحده قد يجر روسيا لحربا مع النيته
والثاني
قوافل الجيش الروسي لم تحظى بدعم الطيران
انظمه باتريوت التي اعلن تسليمها لزيننس
في خلال زيارته واشنطن تحرس الحدود وعد عن
تسليم قطعه واحده منها فقط كما ذكرنا بوتن
له راي اخر
سيرين جدا